[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this [music]
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. We're honored to
continue
All right, let's go ahead and open up
the doors to Daily with Doc. Hello,
everybody. My name is Becca Dukes, and
as the hostess of Daily with Doc and
Becca, I am excited to say hello to you.
So, come on in
and uh make sure that you've got that
part that chat open so that you can see
the great information that is being
shared through the chat. And if you are
watching us on one of the live streams
that are not here in the Zoom room, and
you would like to join us, you are
welcome to do so. Just go to
dailywithdoczoom.com.
That's dailywithdoczoom.com
all together. Make sure you put it in
the URL, not in the search bar,
depending on what platform you use for
your internet,
it does make a difference. So, I'm
excited to be able to share information
with everybody. It was something that I
was missing, even though I was
unquote eating well, according to the
pyramid, and I wasn't taking in a bunch
of junk. My health was in really bad
shape, and it was going downhill. In
fact, at 40, I felt like I was
goodness. I want to say 80 plus, but the
doctor that we have on with us is right
in that, and he doesn't feel his age.
So,
I don't know, maybe I felt 160, Doc.
Beyond what I should have at 40, and
when I fell at 30 and broke my back, uh
it shared a lot of information in that
MRI that the doctor actually thought
that he was coming in to see somebody
65, 70 years old in very poor health
because of all the inflammation,
arthritis throughout my entire body, in
addition to the compression fractures
that I had experienced, and the bone
spurs that were everywhere. And at that
time, I didn't have, at least I didn't
know about blood sugar issues,
but with my last pregnancy,
it
I didn't have gestational diabetes,
but afterwards, it hit just threw me
into
what they call now metabolic syndrome.
And that's something that we're going to
be talking about, messed up blood sugar,
metabolic syndrome, all the things that
go with the symptoms of
the
pancreas just not working right, the
cells not being able to utilize that
insulin that is being emitted into the
system.
And Dr. Wallach is one of the
authorities on being able to share this
information with us. Now, if you were
invited by somebody specific, we want to
make sure that you get back with them.
They cared enough and took the time to
share this show with you, and we want to
make sure that you get back with them.
Tell them what you liked best about the
show, and then if you have any
questions, they probably have some great
answers or know resources to get those
questions answered, and also are able to
help you get on a track to a better
health journey.
Now, I do want to do a special shout-out
um because of um
I don't Can I say the word censorship?
As of censorship, folks, uh we were put
on a time-out on one of the platforms,
so we sent out a email
to our listening audience, those that
are subscribed to our newsletter, so you
want to make sure that you're subscribed
to our newsletter. Go to
dailywithdoc.com.
Um we're also part of the Critical
Health News family, so you can go to
criticalhealthnews.com,
sign up for that newsletter as well. But
we put out a public service announcement
and requested that folks uh follow us on
Rumble. So, we are absolutely loving
Rumble. So, I want to do a special thank
you to all of you who are watching us on
Rumble and who have decided to support
Dr. Wallach's mission of sharing health
choice freedom
by empowering us to be able to
accumulate knowledge. So,
that's that knowledge, folks, is
something that can save our lives, save
the lives of those around us, and
even because, you know, there's always a
time to be born, a time to die, but why
not live life enjoying
to its fullest and optimal well-being,
even if we've gone on a path towards
decline? It's not too late.
And that's what this program is all
about, making sure people know that you,
as an empowered individual, have
choices,
and the food what we need is just not
there.
So, Dr. Wallach, he is uh just an
amazing individual who started out with
some health issues of his own at a very
young age. He I think he was divinely
guided to find solutions for his own
problems that then has brought him to
the point of having under his belt being
a lead pathologist on
an amazing expedition to save the white
rhino, going from around 200, 300 rhinos
to now 16,000 or more in the United
States, and it was because of his work
and what he did in helping to save that
white rhino that then
helped him also to put him in a position
where he could find the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis in a rhesus
monkey and prove that it was not
genetic. So, think about it.
A disease said to be human, said to be
genetic, and he disproved it.
And not only he did he disprove it, he
got fired for it because it was against
the narrative.
And he wrote a book, and he also got an
award for his study in the importance of
selenium. So, without further ado, I
just want to welcome Dr. Wallach to the
screen with me. Dr. Wallach.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Dr. Wallach. [clears throat]
>> How are you today?
Okay, I'm just going to throw this up
there since we're talking about that.
Oh, I'm going to do that, too. So, you
can talk without that being in the way
of your microphone. Okay, very good.
Share with us, Doc. I mean, you're 84
years old going by the Chinese calendar,
which we're coming up on another Chinese
New Year. Yep. Really next week, right?
Yep. And I'll be 85.
And And then you'll be 85. Yep. So,
>> [clears throat]
>> you've gone around the world.
Literally, yeah.
>> Literally. Literally, around the world.
Yeah, with the military and with the
science programs.
And Dr. Wallach,
what has been your favorite
high point in what you have done
to save humanity and the world?
Well,
you know, I'm I'm young kid, right? And
the thing that um
um
told me
that the standard medical science
was backwards
>> [clears throat]
>> um occurred
in 1922.
I was not there yet.
I was just going to say I was back in
1882.
No, 1820
1822, excuse me, 1822. Okay, 1822.
And um in 1822
um
the
let's see here, we had
uh
problems
because we switched over after thousands
and thousands and thousands of years of
using wood and coal as fuel and
employing the wood ashes and coal ashes
into our food as a supplement and also
putting them in the gardens as a
fertilizer.
no, 1822, excuse me, 1822, we
>> [clears throat]
>> noted that suddenly
we had a problem.
What happened
in 1822? Well, we switched over to
electricity and there were no more wood
ashes to put in the gardens and our
food. There was no more coal ashes to
put in our gardens and our food.
And all these mineral deficiencies
started showing up that we had avoided
for couple of thousand years because we
weren't you know, we weren't using the
wood ashes and coal ashes anymore.
>> [clears throat]
>> And nobody knew uh in 1822 why it was
happening. They just knew it was
happening.
Okay?
And so um
>> [clears throat]
>> those things
listed
okay, in history, and you read them and
you say, "Wait a minute, there's a
problem here." Okay? And so
>> [clears throat]
>> um growing up on a farm and in animals
is one of the things we we saw when
animals had a problem the veterinarians
would give the animals alfalfa pellets
with vitamins minerals added to it and
the disease would go away.
Uh one of my favorite ones
that [clears throat] got me to working
with Jerry Lewis
okay? And um muscular dystrophy
and uh it showed that animals
when they didn't have
when they didn't have the
minerals
okay?
The the they needed
they got
um
type 2 diabetes.
They got muscular dystrophy.
And so muscular dystrophy in animals
originally was called white muscle
disease cuz instead of being red like a
normal muscle, it was kind of a creamy
color, so they they called it white
muscle disease. It was it was just um
very simply
the the thing going on.
>> [clears throat]
>> Excuse me, with muscular dystrophy.
Well,
when I saw this going through veterinary
school
and I saw the under the microscope
the muscular dystrophy in human muscle
and white muscle disease in animal
muscle, it was the same disease under
the microscope. You couldn't tell which
was the animal and which was the human.
Okay? Essentially the same.
So, we started giving humans
um the same
minerals. We started giving minerals
to humans
that we had been giving to animals
to get rid of muscular dystrophy
and it went away.
And we we gave the information to Jerry
Lewis
okay?
And he took it to the Muscular Dystrophy
Association. They fired Jerry Lewis
summarily, put a gag order on him so he
couldn't tell the public and the media
that we had found the cause prevention
cure for muscular dystrophy
and the next day he shut down the
telethon which he had been doing for the
Muscular Dystrophy Association for 46
years and he had raised $2.3 billion for
them over 46 years. He shut it all down.
Not him.
Or they did That was the government did
it.
Was it the government or was it the
Muscular It was both. It was the it was
the
medical system connected They couldn't
do it without connecting with the
government.
Okay? So, it was it was the Muscular
Dystrophy Association and then the
government medical divisions
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> to shut everything down.
And so when I came along
you know
60 years later
um it was very impressive for me.
And so I started working my way through
veterinary school
cuz I didn't have enough money, so I was
working my way through veterinary school
working in the pathology department and
I'm comparing diseases in animals with
diseases in humans because of this
muscular dystrophy issue. Okay?
And so this is very very interesting to
me.
And so again, it's one of the things
where
it worked out really nice. So, we know
that thyroid likes iodine.
Okay? You don't have enough iodine, you
get a goiter or you get a big goiter
down here and the thyroid doesn't work
very well without the iodine.
And the ones that they weren't paying
attention to
was the muscular dystrophy. Okay,
muscular dystrophy
is a deficiency again
of
minerals.
And then when you start looking at
um
things like diabetes
okay? It's another deficiency of
minerals.
Okay? And the pancreas, the pancreas
required a lot of minerals
that's we able to work and function
properly. Okay? And we're talking about
chromium and vanadium and magnesium
>> [clears throat]
>> uh and iodine and those kind of things.
Also, the thyroid needed iodine.
So, those two organs
okay? The pancreas and the thyroid gland
required enormous amount of these
nutritional minerals.
Okay? You think about vanadium,
chromium, magnesium uh for
for um
when it came down to the
um
pancreas working properly and
um sugar problems and so forth. Then the
thyroid gland, iodine and copper
when they [clears throat] didn't have
enough
their metabolism didn't work right and
they would gain a lot of weight.
And so that was probably one of your
early issues. Um you know, when you
gained 100 and what? 125 lb or 120 lb.
Yeah, okay?
And so
and now you're a beautiful slim young
woman
because you've been doing the right
things, avoiding the bad food and
supplementing properly.
>> [clears throat]
>> And so you're
an icon in the world. People know of
your story.
Okay? So, I can't thank you enough for
helping to save so many people and so
many animals by doing your story.
And so we thank you. Thank you. Thank
you for that. But we came out in
Youngevity with Sweeties. Okay? Our
Sweeties, this is our
chromium vanadium uh product.
I got mine right here, too. And there
you go.
And then as for
diabetes, the interesting thing about it
is this product contains not only the
the plain minerals, but also uh
chlorella kelp, which has the minerals
from the sea. Uh spirulina, Irish moss,
again, minerals from the sea. Um
Atlantic
wakame,
um dulse um
Porphyra
ulmatum, I think it is. Sea lettuce.
Okay? Wakame. Remember, these are all
sea vegetables.
Okay? And what is the sea? What what
makes the difference in the sea and the
Great Lakes?
Well, the sea has salt in it.
Okay? It has chromium, vanadium.
Okay? It has
uh Minerals.
It has minerals in it. Okay?
And so this is why
um
when they began to boil sea water to get
salt
people with thyroid goiter went away in
a couple of weeks, which they had goiter
for 20 years. And then when you have
pancreas problems, you weren't absorbing
your food and you had all kinds of food
and dietary problems and weight gain and
so on.
>> [clears throat]
>> And you're taking these uh
using
sea salt to flavor your food and so
forth
these things all went away
because of the minerals that were in the
sea salt
okay? It was helping the pancreas and
helping the thyroid.
And so
this is why we have
also Ocean's Gold.
To help support the thyroid. To help
support the thyroid. Okay? Ocean's Gold.
Okay?
And then it also helps support every
organ, every
gland every tissue in the body.
Okay? Same way here. You look at the
list of ingredients
in these two products, it'll blow your
mind. Okay? And so, when people have
uh problems that have these
deficiencies, I say, "Take your 90
essential nutrients.
Take the healthy brain and heart pack so
your tissues have everything they need
to repair themselves.
And then,
even if even if you don't have a thyroid
problem, yeah, you still want to take
the Ocean's Gold.
Okay? Because it has
the um
Uh let's see here. Ocean's Gold has
iodine and the copper in it. And you
also want to take the SweetEase. And
when you look at the list of ingredients
again, on the SweetEase, it blows your
mind
because it has all the things
that either have
the right minerals in it
>> [clears throat]
>> or helps you use those minerals better.
So, these are two of my favorite
products
to add to, whether you have a disease or
not,
you want to add them to your 90
essential nutrients. Take these things
and you won't get tired,
>> [clears throat]
>> you know, in the afternoon take suddenly
and I say, "I'm getting a little
sleepy." Because your blood sugar is
dropping and that kind of thing.
That won't happen if you're taking these
things along with the 90
and staying away from uh eating high
sugar foods. Okay? And you'll add
25 to 50 healthy years to your life.
You'll add 25 to 50 healthy years to
your life.
>> [clears throat]
>> Is that worth an extra two bucks a day?
I think so.
Oh, that's worth an extra 10 bucks a
day, Dr. Wallach. Well, I'm just talking
I'm just talking about a couple of Just
those those two things. Yeah.
Absolutely. Absolutely. But, I want to
just point out one thing. So, that the
ingredients that you
uh named off there, Dr. Wallach, those
are in the Ocean's Gold. So, we want to
make sure that we keep that keep that
straight because in the
uh SweetEase, yes, it has the chromium.
It has the vanadium, but it also has
other
um herbs that and nutrients that are
synergistically blended to help control
and give balance to blood sugar. So,
it's that help with
whether your blood sugar is high or low
or is it just mainly high?
Um it's primarily high, but it will help
it if your blood sugar is low.
Okay?
Um but, because it'll help stabilize
your blood sugar, it won't be going up
and down up and down up and down like
that. And um this is one of those things
where
uh when people are gaining weight, okay?
And they're eating six and eight meals
and snacks a day,
uh that's because they're nutritionally
deficient. They're deficient in these
nutrients, particularly minerals. Okay?
And you develop a a behavior called
pica.
And they'll start chewing on paper and
eating paper and and little kids will
eat bad things, you know, even bowel
movements or whatever. It's like crazy.
When they are missing those nutrients,
they're driven. They have this
And you see this
um
>> [clears throat]
>> in animals, it's called pica
in animals. And in horses, they chew on
the fences and the gates and everything,
it's called cribbing.
They're missing those minerals.
It's why they're chewing on the fence.
Well, and as a farm kid, we saw that a
lot and
it did it reduced whenever we started
putting out those salt blocks,
especially the ones that were red
because they had extra selenium in them.
Um that then created just healthier
offspring and
it's amazing, Dr. Wallach, how simple
it is
and something that medical community has
made so complex thinking that there is
no hope and there's no other way other
than masking symptoms.
And
you were mentioning about the white
muscle disease.
And as I go to the market and I'm
looking and picking out my meat,
I've always been drawn to that darker
color.
And it's you look at the the meat we're
talking beef here, folks. Beef, lamb,
and it's so pale.
Is is there more nutrition or if there
is like white muscle disease in that
pale pale looking meat?
>> Remember, they're they're
>> [clears throat]
>> uh actually um
killing them when they're like 6 months
old.
And so, this is why their their muscle
is pink instead dark red purple. Okay?
Muscle should be dark red purple. Okay?
And so, when you're seeing meat is pink,
uh stay away from it because it's a
serious
uh nutritional deficiencies. Not just
one, it's got multiple nutritional
deficiencies.
And and including copper and
selenium [clears throat] and
uh
magnesium and vanadium and chromium and
all those things.
And and so, you'll pay the price if
you're eating the meat that looks pink.
All right. And uh Dr. Wallach, I just
wanted to go through some of the
symptoms that are associated with blood
sugar levels uh cuz a lot of people will
be told, "Well, you're not diabetic or
you're not diet borderline diabetic."
Which I wasn't diabetic. I wasn't
borderline diabetic. But,
I wasn't able to lose the weight that I
had gained and it just piled on. I mean,
I gained 60 lb with my last pregnancy.
>> Well,
just because you were deficient. You
were deficient in minerals. It's not
just chromium and vanadium and
>> [clears throat]
>> those kind of It's all minerals. When
you're deficient in all the essential
minerals, there are 60 of them. If
you're deficient in any one or two,
you have this pica behavior. You want to
eat eat eat eat. Okay? And so, it's not
just um the the um iodine. It's not just
the
>> [clears throat]
>> uh chromium vanadium. It's not just the
copper. Okay? It's all the minerals that
we require. If any of them are low or
not there,
you're going to develop
pica and cribbing
uh just like the horses.
So, what what if you don't have that
sensation of not being satisfied?
It's cuz I didn't eat eat eat eat. In
fact,
the more I didn't eat,
the more I gained.
Cuz I'm thinking, "Okay, I need to stop
eating. Everything I eat is just turning
to fat."
So, I cut way back when I the more I
dieted, the more I gained.
Because after I had my son, I gained
another 60 lb within 2 months.
It was Were you Were you breastfeeding
him?
I was.
Okay, you should have been losing
weight, not gaining weight.
Understood. It wasn't working the way it
was supposed to, Dr. Wallach.
But,
you know, a lot of the the symptoms that
are said to be associated with blood
sugar issues, whether you have
the disease or not, I mean, you're
thinking thirst, headaches, trouble
concentration, blurred vision, weight
gain, weight loss, weakness, um skin
infections, slow healing of cuts and
sores,
nerve damage, like the neuropathies,
um intestinal problems, constipation,
diarrhea,
it the list just goes on and on and on.
Cold feet, cold fingers because the
circulation is not getting out there.
Um that they're saying is caused because
of too much blood or too much sugar in
the blood,
feeling sick,
um
just there's so so many things, Dr.
Wallach. It seems like the symptoms
associated with blood sugar issues that
are listed here are symptoms that are
associated with many other conditions,
also.
Well, it's not unusual to have
uh when you are missing something, it
it's not unusual to be missing
four or five or six or eight or 10 or 25
different minerals. And so, you can have
16 to 30 different diseases
associated with uh mineral deficiencies.
>> [clears throat]
>> And with there being what, over 600
poor health conditions or symptoms
associated with mineral deficiencies,
That's correct.
>> folks,
if you're not feeling great, it's
probably because of a mineral
deficiency, not a chemical deficiency.
Well, how can you tell if you have a
mineral deficiency?
A hair analysis.
Hair analysis.
Yeah, a hair analysis.
And
>> [clears throat]
>> and this is a good investment in your
health.
Uh if you do a hair analysis, like uh
start out once every 3 months. Then you
get everything under control, do it once
a year.
And that hair analysis
is going to be one of your best friends.
Say, "Oh,
I'm a little low here on my iodine.
That's going to affect my thyroid
gland."
Okay? So, you start really working on
the iodine salts
on your salads and things like that and
your soups and so on.
>> [clears throat]
>> And uh don't forget your
Let's see here.
How about How about sea salt, Dr.
Wallach? Like a Celtic sea salt that's
coming from the ocean in a clean source.
Sea salt. And of course, this is salt
that we put into Ocean's Gold.
It's a sea salt.
>> [clears throat]
>> And uh so, as you get the iodine and the
copper,
and you get the kelp
and the seaweed uh has all these sea
salt and sea minerals in it.
And so it's one of those things um
uh
sea lettuce, okay?
Uh Irish moss, spirulina, all these
things, chlorella, all these things that
have access
to salt water, okay?
Um and this is why
uh people who um live in the islands
tend to be healthy and they aren't
always, but they tend to be healthier if
they're, you know,
um [clears throat]
eating fish caught there, eating plants
grown uh in the sea salt water, okay?
Sea vegetables, kelp, that kind of
thing. You're you're getting this stuff
that's in the ocean.
>> [clears throat]
>> And when you look at the people who live
long as the peoples,
the people in Hunza, okay?
Um
and
they
their their average lifespan is 122.
Our average lifespan
is like 75 or something like that, okay?
Yeah, quite a bit less. Yeah, medical
doctors,
well, let's see here, ones that work in
emergency rooms, their average life
expectancy is 58.
Yeah, even less.
Well, Dr. Wallach, um I I have lots of
comments and I've got a couple hands
that are up here and some questions. I
know um Balaji says I've been eating
ashes and I'm 80 with a big old smile
there, so that's fantastic. Taking in
those nutrients. And you know, one thing
that I noticed, Dr. Wallach, is in those
areas that have less industry, you have
fewer processed foods. So you're eating
more whole foods and you're doing things
that are on a much healthier level. So I
think that's going to be fantastic
um to be able to share this information
and just encourage people to go more
back towards roots and doing things it
like
gardening. And where we may not have the
opportunity to put wood ash in our
gardens, we do have the blooming
minerals that are available that are
from Youngevity, the company that Dr.
Wallach was the founder of. So there's a
lot of things that we can do on our own.
He has put together the company
Youngevity, which he has handed over to
his son and and daughter. So people
can't say, "Oh, you're just promoting
the company because you make a buck."
It's like, no, that's not how he makes
his money. He's making his money off the
sale of his books. So he was just
holding up the book
uh Wallach Revolution, which is the
authorized um autobiography or
biography. It's not auto cuz he didn't
write it, but it was the it is the
authorized biography of Dr. Wallach and
his journey. He's got the Hell's
Kitchen, which which goes through the
change from electric or from wood ash
into electricity. There are some recipes
in there as well. And you can find the
recordings for our programming out on
almost every platform out there.
So um
one of our co-hosts, AJ, he has been
very instrumental in helping us get out
onto the different platforms, including
on Roku TV and Fire TV and Apple TV.
You can find our channels or app on
those places as well. But make sure that
you go to Rumble and follow us on
Rumble. Cuz when all else fails, Rumble
has been a fantastic backup for us. So
you know, it's they've got our front,
they've got our back. Let's just go
Rumble, folks. Uh look up for Critical
Health News or you can do a search for
Daily with Doc and you'll find our
channels there.
Um we're also on Facebook. You can
follow us on Facebook, follow us on
YouTube, all the different places. Let
us know that you are there. So put up a
heart, put up a like, send us a comment,
and most of all, go to our website
dailywithdoc.com
and sign up for our email list so that
when we put out an email, you make sure
that you are getting that right into
your email box. We're doing summaries of
each of the shows and including the
shows in that email so that you can
easily find them and then share them.
And as a thank you for those who share,
those with the most points cuz you can
earn points for sharing, then will be
receiving a thank you gift from me. So
sign up for that giveaway at dwg
giveaway.com.
That's dwg giveaway.com.
Well, Dr. Wallach,
let's go to some questions.
Let's go for it. Let's go for it.
>> All right. Well, let's go to the first
question and the first hand that is up
and
area code 160. So I'm going to say your
area code starts with 60. Go ahead and
unmute yourself if you can.
Hello, hello.
So if you can hear me and you're not
seeing There you go.
Hello, welcome to Daily with Doc.
Yes, um my name is uh Joyce and I would
just like to start by saying that um I
want to thank him very much. I'm 77
years old and I talked to him back in
and um
he I he talked to me uh at length, asked
me lots of questions, and he told me
about the minerals in Utah, and I
started I took his advice and I started
taking those minerals,
and I have been
super healthy
and I've stayed away from doctors, and I
stayed away [clears throat] from
medicines,
and um
I also would like to mention that um
well, people say I don't eat very much,
but I think most people eat too much,
and I stay away from um
the
uh
the the
fast food places, don't go to
McDonald's, I don't eat any um
junk stuff like that. I do occasionally
have some ice cream after dinner, maybe
a fruit dessert or something. Um
I like meat,
and uh
I like fruit, and I like um some of the
grains. Um
I don't like vegetables.
Um but my problem now
is in the last couple of years, I uh the
only medicine I'm on and have been on is
uh
the inhalers.
I um I have a breathing problem.
I get low on oxygen,
and I was in the hospital several times,
and they finally put me in the um
hospital for 3 days and did all kinds of
tests. They tested everything. All kind
of fluids from my body and
um
they scanned and X-rayed, all kinds of
tests, and I have implement um
>> [clears throat]
>> emphysema.
But the doctor, after all the tests were
done, came in Yeah, and they tested my
heart uh and all that. Um put me on
those machines. Everything was good, and
he said I do have emphysema, but not to
the extent that it should be causing
these symptoms.
And he said the other two causes could
be um allergies or emotional problems.
And so um
right now I take an inhaler
every about every 12 hours,
and um
and now I'm on like if I
>> [clears throat]
>> am walking around a lot, I sometimes
need some oxygen. And so that's my
story.
And thank you. Thank Yeah, that's a
great story. Thank you for your Yeah,
thank you for sharing.
Um that's a great great story and you're
you're you're going to be rewarded for
all the good things you've done because
you're be healthier and you'll add many
healthy years to your life. Now,
when you have uh
the um
an oxygen problem,
you could have osteoprosis in the skull
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve, which
helps control how your lungs work, okay?
Now,
um
let's see here.
Uh what
what um
let's see here. Do do do do
Do you have any ringing in your ears?
No. I mean, I I have occasionally
um
but you know, probably
never lasts in probably a couple years.
>> a while, once in a while, okay. And what
about uh any balance problems? Do you
have to hold onto the rail going up the
steps?
No, I rode horses all my life. I've got
really good balance.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, good. All right. Well, those are
some of the things that tell you have
something going on uh with your
um
uh skull, osteoprosis skull. Also, you
could have a little sugar problem. I had
an injury with a pinched nerve in my
neck Mhm.
years ago. Okay, well, make sure you're
taking the collagen or gluco gel.
Okay,
uh ensure body what you go ahead and
take two or three of those twice a day
of the gluco gel.
And then it's going to help rebuild
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, bone matrix,
um and
um so forth.
And so that will help in those areas.
>> [clears throat]
>> And the lungs, again, we when you help
your spinal cord,
you're helping your lungs. When you help
your brain, you're helping your your
spinal your spinal cord and your lungs,
okay?
And so it's one of those things where
um you have to do the whole thing, the
90 essential nutrients plus
um
uh
you know, wouldn't hurt to take our
sweeties and also take the oceans gold,
take those things. They're going to help
you with energy.
They're going to help you
uh get more oxygen from the environment.
Okay.
a couple of weeks.
Okay, so basically I need to take
everything then or is there
>> Take the 90 Take the 90 essential
nutrients.
Yeah. How much do you weigh?
I weigh 132
lb. Okay, well, just uh get a one
healthy brain and heart pack for a
month. Uh take a half a dose at
breakfast, half a dose at dinner time.
Okay?
And then go ahead and take uh two or
three of the oceans gold twice a day,
take two or three of the sweeties twice
a day.
And then if you want some oxygen,
what wonderful product do we have,
Becca,
that's an oxygen product?
Um so we do have the oxy body. It says
it right here in the name of the
product, oxy body. Well, there you go.
Oxy body cherry berry. You want to make
sure that you take that on an empty
stomach. So,
uh take it before eating, especially
when you've got some lung issues going
on. Uh
And you can take it at bedtime, too. So,
1 oz
um is all you need, which is 2 Tbsp, and
that's what the cap is. So, take that on
an empty stomach a couple times a day.
Very good. Yeah, new collagen every
couple of weeks and you know, let us
know what you did, add to your program,
and let us know how you're doing. Uh
people want to hear from you.
>> um I do have sea salt that comes from a
cove in France, and they don't wash it.
It comes wet with all the minerals in
it. So,
do I need to take that extra salt?
Uh yes, now I'd be careful
when you're getting, you know, just salt
taken from the coast of France and
they're sending it to you. You don't
know if there's chemicals from the
industry and all that kind of stuff in
there.
Um I'd like to see a an analysis of
that. If they have an analysis of it,
let's read [clears throat] the analysis
and see if there's any contamination
from
uh industrial chemicals.
Okay.
All right, thank you so much, Joyce.
Hey, are they acid sorry day a capsule
or are they a
liquid?
So, what
The essential essential fatty acids
offered by Youngevity, they are soft
gels.
And one thing that you want to make sure
when you're looking at essential fatty
acids, because when
oils are taken from their natural state,
that takes away the things that preserve
them, too.
Oils, oxygen don't go well together. It
creates oxidation. So, you want to make
sure that you are taking in products
that
are taken
from start to finish in a nitrogen-rich
environment, so it doesn't have that
exposure to oxygen, so that you're not
putting
free radicals in your body.
So, yes, essential fatty acids are very
important for lung and skin health. You
don't want to forget those.
Okay. All right.
Well, thank you very, very much. Thank
you for your time. I really appreciate
it. Thank you. Let's hear from you in a
couple of weeks.
Okay. Thank you. Yes, thank you so much
for calling.
And Dr. Wallach,
>> [clears throat]
>> let's go to KSCO and Dave Michaels.
Dave, go ahead and unmute yourself.
Okay, can you hear me?
Yes, sir.
How you doing, Mike? I am doing just
fine, Dr. Wallach. I have a question on
behalf of a client of mine, and it's
about her friend who is in her mid-50s,
5 and 1/2 ft tall,
98 lb.
She's uh recently been around somebody
who was uh sick with COVID. She has not
been diagnosed, but in any case, she's
suffering from severe weight loss.
Um her doctor does have her on some
supplements.
Her appetite is not bad.
She doesn't eat enough, obviously, cuz
she's underweight, but her appetite is
not bad, and uh she wants to know what
you suggest in order to make sure that
she is ready to deal with any type of
illness or even to gain weight, and just
your advice in general, Doc. Okay, two
things. Number one, she needs to avoid
all the bad foods. No fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat, barley, oats, no buckwheat, no
sugar, no carbonated drinks. Even the
diet ones got to go.
>> [clears throat]
>> And at 90 lb,
I want her to have um one healthy brain
and heart pack for a month.
Okay? There's 215 different nutrients
in the healthy brain and heart pack.
Take a half a dose of everything at
breakfast and have a dose of it at
dinner time. Okay?
And then
um she if she wants to, uh she can take
some um
like our rebounder sports drink. Okay?
And uh go ahead and uh
>> [clears throat]
>> uh I like to rebound because it gives
you energy
um and gives you more minerals.
And so she can have rebound two, three
times a day, you know, say um an hour or
so after dinner.
I wouldn't take it before bedtime cuz
you might stay up all night, okay?
And that's that's basically What about
if she wants to gain weight? Is there
any way a healthy way to gain weight?
Well, she needs to do light exercise,
walking,
>> [clears throat]
>> you know, doing sit-ups and push-ups and
that kind of stuff, going on a swing,
>> [clears throat]
>> and do some light exercise.
But she does need to feed her her
muscles and skin and and so forth.
And so this is something
um if she's not allergic to milk, she
can have cheese.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh she can drink milk, she can have
cheese, that kind of stuff.
Uh she needs a little bit of fat to gain
some weight and have energy.
And so cheese and milk
are good sources.
You know, the good Lord made milk,
and we make cheese out of the milk. And
the good Lord made
and all mammals,
okay,
>> [clears throat]
>> are producing milk to feed the babies.
It's their first first food for the
first couple of weeks or couple of
months, depending on the species.
And so this is a message.
I have one more question, Dr. Wallach.
This is from another customer of mine.
He wants to know if caffeine, coffee,
will affect the absorption of minerals
that he's taking.
Uh caffeine does affect
uh the utilization of of minerals, okay?
Because it it impacts
uh
>> [clears throat]
>> it uh kind of crushes the hunger
um sensations
uh cuz it pulls
um
>> [clears throat]
>> fat and sugar out of your body to raise
it very quickly in your bloodstream.
And so
it's one of those [clears throat] things
where
it's not unusual to have fluctuations in
your weight. You can lose a lot of
weight if you drink a lot of caffeine,
you can gain a lot of weight if you
drink a lot of caffeine and you're
having your biscuits with it and that
kind of stuff.
So,
um I do drink decaffeinated tea.
Okay? No caffeine in the tea,
okay?
But I do drink decaffeinated tea.
>> [clears throat]
>> It's a Youngevity product.
So, we have lots of options when it
comes to beverages and to help um
control
not just thirst, but also add nutrition
into your body with every sip. So,
hopefully that helps with the answer to
your question there, Jade. And I know
Dr. Wallach, it is time for us to to end
our time with you. Thank you so much for
joining us here on Daily with Doc. We
greatly appreciate you and your time.
Thank you. God bless each and every one
of you.
God bless you as well, Doc.
And if I could get my co-hosts on the
screen with me, I'd greatly appreciate
that. Folks, I could not do this by
myself. Um I tried, and it was a little
on the stressful side. So, to be able to
have this
army
and on this crusade with me who just
absolutely have been touched by Dr.
Wallach's message and have this inside
drive to help others and make sure they
get the message as well, has really been
a benefit to all of us, folks. Um I
consider myself very blessed to be able
to have the people on the screen with
me, um including some that are not Not
just some, a lot that are not on the
screen as we together are helping get
the message out so that more and more
people within our families, our
communities, and together within our
world can find better health.
We have Sherry who is helping to uh
bring people into the room also. She's
working on the technical side with AJ
making sure that the
streams are going and set up. Everything
has to be set up just right before every
show and then taken down just right
after every show. So, thank you Sherry
for being willing to learn that. Um and
and since I mentioned AJ, we'll go with
AJ next. So, AJ has been very
instrumental as I mentioned earlier in
getting our show out on the different
platforms and on TV. So, I know you
smart TVs, you can watch us on TV, but
folks, there's some people that really
just like to focus on Apple TV. We're
there. Roku, we're there.
Fire TV, we're there. And I love it. I
can
I can go on and see see our faces and
and the message and just share.
So, thank you AJ for all your work on
doing that.
Um we do some really late hours making
sure everything is set up just right.
And we have Phyllis who is joining us.
She is one of the longest standing
members um with Youngevity who has been
very instrumental her and her husband
Andy in getting Dr. Wallach on the radio
whether it's on KCEO KMY and then so
many others
that I don't even have a list of them.
We need to get them We need to get that
list on where we are still being
broadcast and then we're growing, folks.
So, if you are
um associated with a podcast, a radio
program, a broadcast of any sort, make
sure that you get back with us
or our call team, if you're not working
with somebody already, 855-949-3377.
And if you're interested in doing
or adding our program to broadcasts uh
Phyllis is your girl. Her and Andy are
absolutely fabulous in getting people
connected. So, she is one of the options
on our call team.
And then we also have Marilyn. So,
Marilyn is our our fingers and a working
long hours as well and getting all the
information put into the chat here in
our live Zoom. So, I just want to do a
special shout out to to Marilyn as she's
paying like hyper
attention
um to what's being said her and Phyllis
both. So, they do some tag teaming on
that chat. And if you're not here with
us in the live Zoom, you're missing out
on the information shared.
And then we also have Albert Waydown in
South Africa who is helping us with our
um
extended internet uh
international branch. Um
and reaching people around the world.
So, thank you Albert for being here with
us as I know that it is a middle of the
night for you right now as you're 10
hours ahead of us.
Folks, if you have
ever thought of
wanting to share the word of nutrition.
If you've heard Dr. Wallach's message
but you've never taken any steps in
implementing it into your own life
I have so many customers that are coming
to me now saying, "You know what?
I have been following Dr. Wallach's
recommendations. I've been
recommending the program to lots of
people. And my first question is, "Well,
have you ever tried the products?" No, I
never have. I think it's time.
If
that if you can like
you know, since okay, it's time.
Folks, it's never too late. So, get back
with the person that shared this program
with you. If there is no one to thank,
make sure that you give us a call here
on the Daily With Doc team at
855-949-3377.
And we also have an option way to get a
hold of us through our website. Use that
contact option on our website
dailywithdoc.com.
And you can reach me that way. Also,
whenever you sign up for our email list,
there is a
a box there that you can enter in your
questions or comments and and
communicate with us that way as well.
We are in a world where there are a lot
of heating hurting people.
You hearing this message was not by
accident.
Reach out and let's together make this
world a healthier place. As healthier
people are happier people and we are
empowered to do that.
My name is Becca Dukes. Thank you again
for joining us here on Daily With Doc.
Until next time.
Oh, tomorrow Pharmacist Ben. So, we have
our Pharmacist Fridays. I'm super
excited for the information that we're
going to be sharing on that as well.
Bye for now.